so this is one of the biggest problems
that we have and almost nobody has any
idea what to do about it or any will to
do anything Dr Mark Siegel has a sense
of what we should do and he joins us to
tell us what it is Doctor thanks for
coming on hi Tucker you know first of
all it connects to something you started
the show with when you were talking
about Chicago because Chicago is 65 000
homeless and they're overflowing into
the shelters into O'Hare Airport where
there's encampments and a lot of
violence is going on in crime in La
there's 50
000 homeless that don't have shelters in
New York they are sheltered almost 70
000 are sheltered and I'll tell you in a
minute why shelters make a difference as
step one I have three steps for what our
Democrat Mayors could actually do if
they're listening three steps but as you
said mental illness is a big part of
this 13 times more likely to become
homeless if you were in prison domestic
abuse you lose your house you lose your
job that's what we're dealing with here
and mental illness is really high up so
what do you do number one you provide
shelters you've got to have extensive
shelters but that's not enough
affordable housing would be nice and La
does not have that that's why everyone's
fleeing LA and so we need affordable
housing number two we need community
service here we need the community to
get involved and not just give somebody
a place to live but how about something
to do a bridge to jobs maybe give some
payment something to give somebody their
self-worth back and the third idea is we
need to address this mental illness it's
one-third severe mental illness we need
clinics on Wheels in cities that come
and take care of our homeless and deal
with the mental illness parts and in
prisons by the way I told you at the
beginning prisons are heavily involved
in this we need prison reform Tucker
because 85 percent of prisoners are
suffering from drug abuse and I'll tell
you there's one state that's going to
surprise you that actually has a handle
on this it's Rhode Island they do a lot
of reform in Rhode Island so the
homelessness problem if our Democrat
Mayors are listening get some housing
get the medical care and give them
something to do Tucker
Dr Mark Siegel for us saying thank you
very much thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight